Quantum physics is understanding at a fundamental level...
...how the basic particles that make up our entire universe work.
Quantum physics is a branch of Science,...
...which describes the behavior of the particles...
...in a microscopic world.
In this world, systems can display very unusual physical phenomenon...
...such as quantum superposition and quantum entanglement.
It's often had been said that nobody really understands quantum mechanics...
... but the laws of quantum mechanics...
...are in excellent agreement with our experimental observations,...
...which is why we accept it as correct.
Almost everything we do is quantum,...
...because quantum mechanics underlies the physical world.
I've worked with, what we call...
...in the field, quantum dots and quantum wells.
So, quantum is in the title,...
...but more recently I've been working on a particular kind of...
...quantum mechanical unit of information called the qubit.
Quantum physics deals with the properties of nature...
...on very small microscopic length scales.
What we're used to thinking about physics...
...is that it can predict the outcome of certain experiments.
And what I find remarkable about quantum physics...
...is that it essentially only allows you to predict the probability...
...of the outcome of a certain experiment,...
...which basically tells us that nature is not deterministic,...
...but probabilistic.